foreign
I would love to talk about and this is
something that I haven't discussed with
you at any length
the art of minimizing sleep time
and this may tie into cbti which I
really don't know that much about but I
like a lot of people I think have
made the error although it doesn't feel
like an error of getting into bed and
even if my sleep onset takes an hour
hour and a half because maybe I have
that tired and wired feeling which a lot
of people do a lot of veterans people
with PTSD you know suffer from this
overly activated sympathetic nervous
system which I do a lot and I'll just
stay in bed right even if it takes me
three hours to get to sleep I will often
just kind of sit there and try to
meditate my way into Oblivion which
doesn't always work very well so what's
the what's the counter approach yeah so
I think you know one of the the sort of
the conventional tips for sleep you can
find all over the Internet and you know
idiots like me you can hear speaking
about the five tips of beta sleep
hygiene and you know there's very good
evidence for why those are sensible
things to put in place but what about
the unconventional and one of the
unconventional components is to limit
your sleep time as you said there is the
principle
the principal treatment for insomnia
should not be the first line defense of
sleeping pills that we discussed in the
last episode the current recommendation
is something called cognitive behavioral
therapy for insomnia or cbti and as you
can tell by the term it works on two
things cognitive things in other words
your thoughts and your beliefs about
sleep and then your behaviors what are
you not doing that you should do to help
your sleep and what are you doing that
you shouldn't be doing and you should
stop doing to help your sleep and that's
the cbti component
probably if you look across the studies
and cbti has a number of different
features in this treatment this therapy
approach
but one of the most potent tools in the
box of the cbti therapist is sleep what
we call Sleep restriction therapy which
sounds paradoxical you come to me let's
say I'm your sleep clinician you say I
am not sleeping well I'm in bed for
about eight hours but I think I only
maybe sleep four four and a half hours
I'm just not getting enough sleep can
you help me and my response to you is
excellent I've got a great treatment for
you it's called Sleep restriction
therapy and you hear the kind of the
record scratch and you say hang on a
second I just told you I'm not getting
enough sleep and you're telling me we're
gonna restrict my sleep it's actually a
poorly termed phrase it should really be
called bedtime restriction therapy and
it works in the following way that right
now if you take that example you're in
bed for eight hours and you're sleeping
for four hours you have a miserable
sleep efficiency so you have a sleep
efficiency of 50 half of the amount of
time that you're in bed you're awake
half the time you're asleep we want to
see that around about 85 or greater in
terms of your sleep efficiency that's
what we think is healthy
and so
rather than actually having you stay in
bed for any longer we do the opposite
and we use the biology of your brain and
something called Sleep pressure
so from the moment that both you and I
woke up we've been building up a
chemical that we've sort of discussed
with regarding caffeine which was
adenosine
adenosine builds up the sleepier and
sleepier you feel and the longer that
you're awake the heavier that weight of
sleepiness will be weighing you down so
just take the extreme of let's say you
pull an all-nighter or you're awake for
36 hours imagine how tired you are at
that point when you get into bed that
following night it's almost as though
nothing's going to stop you earthquakes
wildfires you you're just going to get
into bed and you're going to be knocked
out why because you've just got so much
sleepiness built up so much adenosine
that hasn't been removed so we do a
diluted version of that in cpti with
sleep restriction therapy where we say
okay you're going to bed just for
argument's sake at midnight and you're
waking up at eight now what I want you
to do is actually compress that window
of time and I want you to go to bed not
at midnight but now push it go to 2 A.M
or 2 30 a.m or let's say 3 A.M but you
still wake up at the same time so where
we restrict your sleep is not by having
you wake up any earlier which is kind of
miserable than most people like most
people feel it's easier to go to bed
later than wake up any earlier so we
start there we limit the amount of time
that you're in bed and we restrict it
down to maybe six hours or five hours
and the next day you're going to feel
miserable you know you've only been in
bed for five hours
but what happens is that as long as you
commit to it and it has to be committed
and you have to work with someone who's
going to motivate you and it is hard but
it works
and after the second night of being in
bed for five hours you've been awake for
longer so now you've been awake for 19
hours during the day and you're only in
bed assuming for five hours
and that increase in your adenosine
because you're awake now for 19 hours
straight for one day for a second day
for a third day it all starts to
accumulate
and then at one point maybe and it
depends on the patient let's say about
four or five days after that they get
into bed at 2 30 a.m or 3 A.M and then
the next thing that they remember is
their alarm going off at 8am and for the
first time ever they have slept all the
way through from front to back now in
that example I've restricted the Bedtime
by three hours
and they're now sleeping a solid five
hours but remember that's better than
where they were they were in bed for
eight hours and they were only sleeping
for four hours so I've added an extra
hour and they're in bed for less time
and then gradually what we do is we
start to back that up once you're stable
and your sleep efficiency is 85 90 then
we'll say okay now go to bed at 2AM and
then now let's go to bed at 1 30 a.m and
now let's try 1am and gradually we back
it off and essentially it's like hitting
the reset button on your Wi-Fi router
you are retraining the Sleep System and
in doing so you can start to get
people's confidence renewed because
that's a big problem with insomnia I
mean I was gonna say it sounds like more
than anything well I shouldn't say that
who the hell am I but it seems like
principle among the reasons that would
work is that you are resetting sleep
related anxiety
hundred percent because when you are
suffering from insomnia and I've had my
bouts too and I know that you know
you've spoken publicly about
struggles before
you go into the bedroom and the bed just
looks like the enemy and you have lost
all confidence in your ability to sleep
and at that point your sleep controls
you
but by way of cbti and sleep restriction
therapy you turn the tables now you
control your sleep not your sleep
controlling you and you regain
confidence that is a huge win I can't
tell you how big that is for people with
insomnia it's a terrible fear when they
go into the bedroom they just convince
themselves it's not going to be my night